tiens berton à l'année 20 charlie est né
avec une malformation congénitale opéré
une première fois que rouvert à 15 jours
de vie il subira une deuxième chirurgie
à l'âge de 4 mois et demi à présent les
espoirs de la famille de ses parents
reposent sur une greffe du coeur
après deux années passées à l'hôpital
sainte-justine charlie rentrer chez elle
à val d'or ne pleurez un peu celle qui
est devenue la coqueluche du service de
soins intensifs va laisser un grand vide
charles et sa famille sont vraiment
incroyables vous savez à la fin car
depuis deux ans plus de deux ans et
c'est la réalité de nos enfants sur la
liste de greffes cardiaques qui peuvent
attendre très longtemps la moitié vont
décéder sur la liste d'attenté charlie
est très charismatique et atypique fait
chaud mais d'habitude n'ont pas eu
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'énergie
je vais bien un regain charlie retourne
attendre son coeur à la maison grâce à
ce sac à dos qu'elle garde sur ses
épaules toute la journée
à l'intérieur une pompe de millery nonne
un médicament vital qui va lui permettre
de voir autre chose que les salles
d'hôpital
quand on retrouve une vie de famille
normalité ça va pouvoir commencer à voir
ses amis voire encore commence à voir
nos familles des choses qui a été mis en
suspens la recherche en pédiatrie est
largement financée par la fondation chu
sainte justine la recherche à
saint-justin c'est vraiment le coeur
c'est ce qu'on doit préserver parce que
pandémie ou pas pandémie les les
problématiques si la science avance à
pas de géant
les délais d'attentes d'un don d'organe
de melon ici à cenon cry et radio canada
montréal